A PISTACHIO SHELL IS HER CANOE.
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
HERE'S AN EXPERIMENT.
TYPE TORTURE INTO GOOGLE AND
WHAT DO YOU GET?
THE ODD SNIPPETS OF HILLARY'S
SPEECHES.
YOU WILL SEE GINA HASPEL, THE
FIRST WOMAN TO BE NOMINATED TO
RUN THE CIA.
A33 YEAR VET.
MORE THAN QUALIFIED TO RUN THE
WORST ENEMIES AND HOW TO HANDLE
THEM.
WHICH MEANS SHE MUST BE STOPPED.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THERE'S
CONTROVERSY IN HER PAST.
SHE WAS INVOLVED WITH THE
TORTURE PROGRAM AFTER
SEPTEMBER 11TH.
AND THEN INVOLVED WITH
DESTROYING VIDEOTAPES OF THE
MATTER.
THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT
COULD BE PROBLEMATIC.
>> I OPPOSE HER BECAUSE SHE
BELIEVES WATERBOARDING SHOULD BE
SOMETHING WE USE, AND I THINK
AMERICA SHOULDN'T BE KNOWN FOR
TORTURE.
>> GINA HASPEL DOES NOT BELONG
AS HEAD OF THE CIA.
SHE BELONGS IN FRONT OF A JUDGE
ANSWERING TO WHAT SHE WAS DOING
RUNNING A TORTURE OPERATION AT A
BLACK SITE IN THAILAND.
>> Greg: DIGGING PRETTY DEEP
FOR THAT ONE.
GINA MADE DECISIONS FEW PEOPLE
EVER HAVE TO MAKE.
THE WORLD SHE OPERATED IN THE
VILLAINS SHE FACED, SHE DIDN'T
HAVE THE LUXURY OF TALKING ABOUT
WHAT TO DO.
SHE HAD TO DO.
THE CALL SHE ANSWERED DEMANDED
IT.
WAS IT TORTURE?
IT WASN'T BACK THEN.
JUST BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE A
TACTIC THAT DOESN'T MAKE IT
TORTURE.
YOU COULD DISCUSS THE MERITS OF
SUCH CHOICES WITH PUNDITS ON TV
RATHER THAN DOING HER JOB.
SHE WOULD PROBABLY BE PAID MORE.
INSTEAD SHE TOOK THE RISK AND
RESPONSIBILITY SO WE DIDN'T HAVE
TO.
SHE RESPONDED NOT JUST OF THE
WORST ATTACK ON OUR COUNTRY
SINCE PEARL HARBOR BUT TO A
WORLD ENDING THREAT.
SURE, IT'S EASY TO SAY IT, BUT
WE ARE BETTER THAN THAT.
FROM A SHINY NEWSROOM.
IF YOU THINK WHATEVER SHE DID
WAS WRONG, WHAT'S YOUR
ALTERNATIVE?
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING BEYOND
"DON'T DO THAT."
HAVE YOU THOUGHT THIS THROUGH?
HERE'S A QUESTION FOR HASPEL'S
CRITICS.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER -- WITH
EVERYTHING THAT'S CONSIDERED
MEAN BE OFF THE TABLE?
SOMETHING TELLS ME YOU WOULD
RATHER LEAVE THE QUESTION OF THE
PEOPLE LIKE GINA HASPEL.
DANA, YOU KNOW THIS STORY
PROBABLY BETTER THAN ANYBODY.
THEY KEEP CALLING THIS TORTURE.
DO THEY HAVE A REASON TO CALL IT
TORTURE?
>> Dana: IT IS THEIR PERSONAL
OPINION.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A LEGAL
THREE ATTORNEYS GENERAL HAVE
LOOKED INTO THIS.
ALL OF THEM HAVE DECLINED TO
PROSECUTE.
THE PROGRAM WAS ENDED WHEN IT
WAS NO LONGER NEEDED.
I THINK ABOUT HER IN TERMS OF A
THREE DECADE CAREER AT THE CIA.
ALL.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, NOW SHE'S NOT
SUITABLE TO WORK AT THE CIA?
SHE HAS BEEN THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE CIA FOR THE LAST YEAR AND
A HALF.
SHE HAS A GREAT REPUTATION
AMONGST NOT JUST REPUBLICANS.
SHE HAS BEEN SERVING SINCE 41'S
ADMINISTRATION BUT ALSO WITH THE
OBAMA TEAM.
WHAT I WOULD ASK PEOPLE TO THINK
ABOUT IS, HAVE WE FORGOTTEN WHAT
IT WAS LIKE ON THE MORNING AFTER
9/11?
AND WHAT WAS HAPPENING?
SHE WAS ACTUALLY FOLLOWING
ORDERS, OKAY.
SHE DID FOLLOW ORDERS THAT WERE
BASED ON A LAWFUL PROGRAM ASKED
FOR BY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES INTO THE SUBJECT
THAT SHE DESTROYING EVIDENCE,
THERE WAS NO CASE THAT WAS
ONGOING WHEN THOSE TAPES WERE
DESTROYED.
THAT MIGHT SEEM TO SOME PEOPLE
LIKE A DISTINCTION WITHOUT A
DIFFERENCE BUT LET ME TELL YOU
IF YOU ARE IN THE CIA, DO YOU
HAVE REASON TO BELIEVE THE
CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WHO ARE GOING TO USE
THIS FOR DECADES.
NOW WE ARE 17 YEARS AFTER THE
FACT AND THEY STILL WANT TO PICK
AT THIS SCAB AND NOT ALLOW A
WOMAN WHO HAS AN AMAZING RECORD
OF PUBLIC SERVICE TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE?
THAT REALLY CHAPS MY HIDE.
IF THERE ARE CLEAR REASONS SHE
SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO RUN
THIS DEPARTMENT THAT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH HER WORK,
THAT HAS NOT BEEN QUESTION.
THE PROGRAM DOES NOT EXIST
ANYMORE.
THAT TO ME, IF THERE IS A
SUBSTANTIAL REASON, FINE.
LET'S HAVE THAT DISCUSSION.
BUT THIS GRANDSTANDING IS
DESPICABLE.
>> Greg: I THINK CHAPPING YOUR
HIDE IS WORSE THAN
WATERBOARDING, FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND.
>> Dana: YOU COULD MAKE THAT
CASE.
HONESTLY, SLEEP DEPRIVATION,
PULLING OUT FINGERNAILS.
>> Jesse: PLAYING GREG'S LOUD
MUSIC.
>> Dana: THEY WOULD PLAY THAT
IN A PRISON.
>> Greg: THEY PLAY A LOT OF
METALLICA AND SLAYER.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE HARDEST
BRIEFINGS I EVER HAD TO DO AT
THE WHITE HOUSE, I WOKE UP IN
THE MORNING, GOT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND THERE
IS THE STORY THAT THE CIA HAS
DESTROYED INTERROGATION TAPES,
AND I THOUGHT OH, MY GOSH.
I TALKED TO EVERYBODY, THE
PRESIDENT, THE VICE PRESIDENT,
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR, NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR.
I REMEMBER HAVING A PRIVATE
MOMENT WITH STEVE HADLEY BEFORE
I WENT TO THE BRIEFING AND HE
SAID DANA, I WANT TO EXPLAIN
SOMETHING TO YOU.
IN THOSE DAYS AFTER 9/11, THIS
COUNTRY HAD TO MAKE SOME REALLY
TOUGH DECISIONS.
AND THEY WERE TOUGH, BUT THEY
WERE LEGAL AND THEY SAVED LIVES.
AND I WENT OUT AND I HAD THE
BEST BRIEFING I'D EVER HAD
BECAUSE I WAS CONFIDENT.
>> Greg: THEY WILL ARGUE
AGAINST HER.
KIMBERLY, IF SHE WAS A DEMOCRAT
UNDER HILLARY, THEY WOULD SAY
ANY OPPOSITION TO HER WOULD BE
SEXIST.
BECAUSE SHE'S A WOMAN.
>> Kimberly: YOU WANT US TO
SAY IT, WE WILL SAY IT.
>> Dana: IS IT GOING TO HELP?
>> Kimberly: SHE IS QUALIFIED.
OKAY, JUAN.
DON'T WORRY.
>> Greg: A LOT OF THINGS MAKE
YOU NUTS.
>> Kimberly: SHE IS RIGHT.
TORTURE IS ANYTHING, SITTING
RIGHT HERE.
WHAT ELSE?
I DON'T LIKE BEETS.
THAT'S ABOUT IT.
>> Greg: BUT YOU LOVE SUPER
BEETS.
>> Jesse: LETS PAY THE BILLS.
>> Kimberly: LET ME SLOW MY
ROLE.
I THINK SHE IS UNBELIEVABLY
QUALIFIED.
MALE, FEMALE, BASED ON HER
RECORD, CAREER OF DISTINCTION,
SOMEONE ABLE TO MAKE TOUGH
DECISIONS WIDELY ADMIRED BY HER
PEERS.
SHE DESERVES THIS POSITION.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE IN A TOUGH
SPOT.
IT WORKS THE OTHER WAY BECAUSE
SHE'S A FEMALE BECAUSE WHEN THEY
WILL SAY WHY ARE YOU MAKING
THESE ATTACKS AGAINST HER?
THIS COULD BE CONSIDERED SEXIST.
SHE SHOULD GET THE JOB, AND I DO
THINK THEY ARE GOING TO PULL A
WHOLE -- SOME OF THE BACKGROUND
AND TACTICS.
THEY ARE GOING TO LIKE THE
FANFARE, FODDER FOR CERTAIN
SHOWS.
>> Dana: THE MORE THEY TALK
ABOUT THIS, THE MORE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING TO LIKE
HER.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
JESSE, THERE WILL BE DEMOCRATS
GALLOPING IN ON THEIR MORAL HIGH
HORSES.
THERE WILL ALSO BE RAND PAUL,
WHO WAS GOING TO PROPOSE POMPEO
AND HASPEL.
>> Jesse: THE OBAMA
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES THAT SPIED
ON REPORTERS, LIGHT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IN FRONT OF CONGRESS.
DID A LOT OF DISGUSTING THINGS
AND THEY DIDN'T BAT AN EYELASH.
GET OFF YOUR HIGH HORSE, GET OFF
YOUR SOAPBOX.
THIS WOMAN IS A PATRIOT.
SHE WAS TRYING TO SAVE LIVES
AFTER 9/11.
I MEMBER GEORGE BUSH SAID
EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAID.
YOU DON'T REMEMBER WHAT IT WAS
LIKE HERE AFTER 9/11.
THEY HAD TO MAKE A LOT OF TOUGH
DECISIONS.
SHE MADE SOME TOUGH DECISIONS,
AND THE HEAD OF HER OPERATION,
JOSE RODRIGUEZ, SAYS ENHANCED
INTERROGATION SAVED LIVES AND
FOILED PLOTS.
YOU KNOW ALSO CITED?
LEON PANETTA, THE OBAMA
INTELLIGENCE CHIEF.
HE SAID ENHANCED INTERROGATION
LED TO THE LOCATION OF USAMA
BIN LADEN.
SPEAKING OF LEON, ALSO BRENNAN,
CLAPPER.
ALL OF THE INTELLIGENCE PEOPLE
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORT THIS WOMAN.
SO DOES DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
THE WHOLE THING ABOUT HER
DESTROYING THE TAPES, SHE WAS
TOLD TO DESTROY TAPES AND SHE
DID.
HILLARY DESTROYED TAPES BECAUSE
SHE WANTED TO COME AND THAT WAS
UNDER AN ACTIVE INVESTIGATION.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE TO ADMIRE
WHAT HE JUST DID THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT LET THEM BOTH OFF THE
HOOK.
THAT'S FINE.
THIS IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
MEDIA BIAS.
THIS IS A WOMAN WHO'S ABOUT TO
SHATTER THE GLASS CEILING.
SO SHE SHOULD BE PRAISED BY THE
LEFT-WING MEDIA.
BUT INSTEAD SHE IS TRYING TO BE
RAILROADED BECAUSE SHE WAS
NOMINATED BY A REPUBLICAN.
THE MEDIA FOR YEARS HAS BEEN
SAYING THAT WOMEN SHOULD BE
CELEBRATED BECAUSE THEY ARE
PLAYING IN THE BIG BOYS LEG AND
THEY ARE TOUGH AND WE NEED
TOUGH, WOMEN WHO CAN TAKE THE
FIGHT TO PEOPLE.
NOW WE ACTUALLY HAVE A WOMAN
LIKE THAT HOMEMADE TERRORISTS
WHINE AND WHIMPER AND THEY ARE
TRYING TO ATTACK HER.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW IT SCARES
ME.
I THINK DEMOCRAT HUSBANDS ARE
GOING TO TELL THEIR WIVES NOT A
SUPPORTER, THEY WANT BECAUSE
THEY ARE SO SUBSERVIENT.
JUAN, I'M GOING TO EVEN THE
ARGUMENT I ALWAYS HEAR THAT OUR
TACTICS, INTERROGATION TACTICS,
FUELED THE PEOPLE WHO HATE US.
IT'S LIKE WE MAKE IT WORSE.
BECAUSE WE ARE LOWERING
OURSELVES TO THAT LEVEL.
IS THAT HOW YOU FEEL?
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK IT'S
VERY AMERICAN TO TORTURE PEOPLE,
AND NEITHER DOES JOHN McCAIN,
WHO WAS TORTURED.
>> Jesse: WATERBOARDING IS NOT
TORTURE.
>> Juan: MAY BE IN YOUR FREE
TIME YOU WANT TO --
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S
RATIONAL OR SANE.
NOBODY IN THEIR RIGHT MIND.
>> Greg: WHAT IS YOUR
ALTERNATIVE?
>> Juan: THERE ARE LOTS OF
ALTERNATIVES.
TALK TO THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, THEY WILL TELL YOU
THEY GET MORE OUT OF PEOPLE WHEN
THEY DON'T TORTURE THEM.
HERE'S THE THING.
I THINK THE KEY HERE IS, WILL
SHE RENOUNCE THE USE OF TORTURE
AND CONFIRMATION HEARINGS?
THAT'S WHAT DIANNE FEINSTEIN HAD
TO SAY TODAY WHICH IS LOOK,
SHE'S GOT A GREAT REPUTATION IN
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
THEY CALL HER A PRO'S PRO.
BUT THE LAW HAS CHANGED.
TORTURE IS ILLEGAL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ALWAYS
PUTTING DOWN THE CIA, HE SAID HE
THINKS TORTURE IS AFFECTED.
WHAT ABOUT MIKE POMPEO WHO WAS
THE FORMER CIA DIRECTOR?
HE HAS SAID I THINK TORTURE
MIGHT WORK.
THE QUESTION BECOMES WAIT A
SECOND.
ARE WE GOING BACKWARDS?
HAVING HAD A MOMENT OF
CONSCIENCE ABOUT THIS, WHERE WE
WERE TORTURING PEOPLE LEAVE AND
AFTER THE FACT.
IT WASN'T LIKE A "24" SCENARIO
LIKE WE NEED INFORMATION.
IT'S BEEN TAKEN CARE OF.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THE RIGHT TO
SAY I NEED THIS INFORMATION.
TAKE EXTRAORDINARY OR ENHANCED
INTERROGATION TACTICS.
BUT THESE PEOPLE SHE WAS
TORTURING, THOSE PEOPLE --
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU WATER BORED
ME WITHOUT THE WATER.
>> Kimberly: THE USE OF THE
WORD TORTURE.
SOME OF THESE GUYS ARE REAL
LOSERS AND REAL WIMPS.
THEY ARE CRYBABIES.
YOU PUT A CATERPILLAR ON THEIR
SHOULDER AND THEY CRY FOR THEIR
MOM AND NO MORE JIHAD AND THEY
SPILL IT.
THAT TO ME IS NOT TORTURE.
>> Greg: IN THE EYE OF THE
BEHOLDER.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> Kimberly: SLEEP
DEPRIVATION, LOUD MUSIC.
THERE HAVE BEEN CHANGES IN THE
LAW AND SHE WILL FOLLOW THE LAW
AS IT CURRENTLY STANDS.
>> Juan: THE KEY POINT IS,
WILL SHE RENOUNCE THE USE OF
TORTURE?
>> Greg: DANA, WOULD YOU BREAK
THE LAW IF YOU COULD SAVE LIVES
AND RUIN YOUR CAREER?
OR WOULD YOU FOLLOW THE LAW AND
WATCH PEOPLE DIE?
THAT'S AN INTERESTING QUESTION.
>> Dana: THAT'S A BAD
HYPOTHETICAL.
SHE DIDN'T BREAK ANY LAWS.
>> Kimberly: DISQUALIFIED
HERSELF BECAUSE --
>> Dana: OBVIOUSLY THIS IS NOT
AN EASY TOPIC.
THE THINGS THESE AGENCIES ARE
ASKED TO DO IS NOT EASY.
DO YOU THINK THEY WANT TO DO
THIS?
THE NOTION THAT SOMEHOW GITMO OR
THESE BLACK TIGHTS FUELED MORE
ANGER AGAINST WESTERN
CIVILIZATION IS PREPOSTEROUS.
>> Jesse: AFTER THESE ENHANCED
INTERROGATIONS WERE NO LONGER
USED, THE RISE OF ISIS SPRUNG UP
RIGHT AFTER.
>> Dana: IT'S AN IDEOLOGY.
>> Jesse: THE OTHER THING
IS --
>> Juan: WHAT DOES THAT HAVE
TO DO WITH ANYTHING?
>> Jesse: YOU SAID WHEN WE
WERE INTERROGATING PEOPLE AND A
ROUGH WAY THAT WAS MAKING THEM
HATE US EVEN MORE.
YOU JUST SET IT.
>> Dana: THEY HATE US NO
MATTER WHAT.
IT'S AN IDEOLOGY.